jamie wants to know the volume of his
gold ring in cubic inches
he gets a rectangular glass with base
three inches by two inches so you see
that here the base is three inches by
two inches and fills the glass four
inches high with water so you see that
over here four inches high with water
jamie drops his gold ring in the glass
and measures the new height of the water
to be 4.25 inches so this is after the
gold ring is dropped what is the volume
of jamie's ring in cubic inches
well when you start with this water
right over here and you add his ring
whatever that volume is of his ring it's
going to displace an equal volume of
water and push it up and so the
incremental volume that you now have is
essentially going to be the volume of
his ring well what is the incremental
volume here
well it's going to be the volume if you
think about going from this before
volume to the after volume the
difference is the base the base stays
the same it's 3 inches by two inches the
difference is to make it a little bit
drawn a little bit neater the base is
the same the difference
the difference is the height the height
now is 4.25 inches after dropping in the
ring so the water went up by 0.25 inches
so it went up by 0.25 let me write that
0.25 inches
is what the water went up by so we could
just think about what is this
incremental volume going to be what is
this incremental volume that i'm drawing
going to be so this incremental volume
right over here that i'm shading in
the purple
well to figure that out we just have to
measure we just have to multiply the
length times the width times the height
times 0.25
so it's just going to be
it's just going to be 3
times 2
times 0.25
3 times 2 is 6
times
0.25 and you could do that either on
paper or you might be able to do that in
your head 4 times
0.25 is going to be 1 and you have 2
more times 0.25 that's going to be 0.5
so this is going to be 1.5
1.5 and we multiplied inches times
inches times inches so this is going to
be in terms of cubic inches
1.5 cubic
inches
is is the volume of jaime's ring which
is actually a pretty sizable volume for
a gold ring maybe he has a very
big finger or he just likes to spend or
i guess his his his whoever bottomed the
ring likes to spend a lot on
gold